right now from the Washington Post
former Mayor Rudy Giuliani is saying
that he is joining president Trump's
legal team in an effort to help
negotiate an end to the Muller probe and
that is just in from the Washington Post
and now while the president isn't
currently a target in the Kohen
investigation he could have some reason
to worry still because according to The
Wall Street Journal one of mr. Trump's
longtime legal advisors just warned him
Cohen could turn on the president if he
is charged Kennedy no but to to want
yeah there have been some procedural
indictments yeah and that just goes to
show you if you cast a big enough net
right you can grab some fish but in the
end what does that do for us does that
make the world a more just place does
that really hold people accountable or
does it just show that if you get enough
warrants and you go through enough stuff
you can pretty much tag anyone with
anything under percent no I think you
got a grand juries it's a great point
from a legal perspective they just toss
everything up against the wall well I
mean I just don't see if Kennedy and I I
mean go back to what jesse was talking
about in this most recent case where
it's portrayed Oh
the feds knocked down Michael Cohen's
door to get these documents how they're
on efficient guess what you know several
layers of government officials and
judges most of them Republicans had to
approve of this it was a legitimate
execution of a warrant and so you have
to keep that in mind but getting back to
Cohen today the big news on Cohen is no
I'm sorry I'm sorry BuzzFeed I'm sorry
it that I was threatening to sue you
oh I'm sorry fusion GPS I'm not suing
you either we don't want any trouble
with you says Cohen yeah
maybe Cohen's attitude is change you
know why is attitudes changing because
he's probably looking at his bank
account and he realizes it he's not
gonna be this lawsuit against BuzzFeed
because it's gonna cost him an arm and a
leg and he's probably up to here in
legal defense bills on being raided so I
think it's more of a monetary issue less
of a factual issue and on the Rosen
students thing Rosenstein was the one
that did approve the raid he's
conflicted I mean he was the one that
wrote the memo saying why Comey should
be fired anyway now he's overseeing an
investigation into whether Trump broke
the law
firing coming you don't see that as a
conflict and he was the one that signed
off on the warrants to surveil the Trump
you the Deputy Attorney General that's
his job right everyone keeps talking
about the advice he was given to by his
attorney again not that I've ever done
anything wrong
but if I've ever had advice from an
attorney it was great advice it had
nothing to do with with Cohen's
character he was telling them as a
lawyer these are things you need to be
aware of don't so he won you and I are
tight you're getting it doesn't mean
there's anything there he's attorney
he's done things that he's supposed to
do as an attorney not all the pretty
some of it ugly that was his job as
things he took on the responsibilities
that come with that and the penalties
from that he's a fixer I was a fixer for
snoop I did things I never told him what
I did it just is a problem over yes it
is
it's Julian sir I can - you're crazy pit
bull who I would want him on my side
this breaking news about Giuliani being
added to the tape it actually it doesn't
surprise me and this is probably a
better place for him than being Attorney
General or having some other formal post
in the administration because he is very
loyal to the president he knows the law
well he's been a US attorney and he
knows how to combat a lot of this stuff
from the inside out but he's also a
politician and he is a fighter and you
know he has remained loyal to the
president even though he wasn't given
one of the plum posts that many thought
he was going to after president Trump's
election and I think they were a little
worried about him going through the
nomination process because some of the
things that might have come out but now
he doesn't have to go through that
process and I liked how they have
couched this is that they're negotiating
the winding down of this deal because
how many months have we heard that this
thing is going to end I mean every other
month it's like we're winding down we're
winding down hopefully this is going to
be an indication that perhaps they are
negotiating a winding down of this
investigation well I think part of this
story today is that Trump can't get most
of the top-notch conservative lawyers in
America to come work for him and so he's
asked he's talking to out there you
besmirch Jay Sekulow Jay Sekulow was
working for
no I'm saying J has lots of ties to lots
of people and beyond Donald Trump but
here's the thing so you get Rudy
Giuliani and Rudy Giuliani by the way in
addition to being former mayor of New
York was a former prosecutor very
successful prosecutor so he has some
insight there he's been out of the game
for a while that's not to the
president's advantage but you noticed
the president was calling a lot of his
former lawyers just last week the Wall
Street Journal today reports one of
those former lawyers tell him go ahead
fire some of these guys get rid of
Rosenstein don't be bashful definitely
don't talk to the investigators so I
think he's reaching out to the old gang
because he can't get the best of current
criminal yeah honestly because he can
get who he wants and who he needs he
listens to a variety of different
opinions and Rudy Giuliani is very well
respected I would not say in any way oh
he's out of the game and not gonna give
the press he still wields a tremendous
amount of influence he was an
outstanding prosecutor take it from one
and I think that he's actually going to
be a very well reasoned measured
addition to the president's team
especially at this juncture you bring in
specialists at certain points and
different phases and just because these
people are saying that they are winding
the investigation down doesn't mean that
they they didn't get a smoking gun that
they're still not going to try and go
after the president but he's also a
former prosecutor and a politician and
knowing the law in politics is really
critical because so much of this and and
you know a lot of the perception going
into the midterms and 2020 hinges on
this and the outcome of it and that's
why it's really important to have
someone who can do both things a Blee
plus Trump is a loose cannon as a lawyer
to tell him what did you gonna tell the
president our president what to do so
chances are he has to refer to guys who
have told him what to do in the past he
can have that conversation but as a
client
he's very difficult because you'll say
listen Murray I'm talk about anything
and then he'll go out and tweet and say
what's on his mind someone who says I'm
wrong so a lot of attorneys don't want
that headache because they cannot rein
him in where Giuliani him have a
relationship maybe I should miss guys
he's worked for in the past they know
how to deal with him so I think it's
more of that opposed to why wouldn't you
not want to be on the front end of the
fight for
sometimes you go back to your roots
right now at school you're after because
he's old school
yeah I think that's look that's why John
dad's no longer there he won't listen to
you yeah he's like peace John down